so um I'm not an actor at all I'm really
a writer who just acts cajon me to
create a character all you have to do is
really get the hare rights the costume
right but I'm a star Sean and then get
the voice right that's I think
caricature acting not real emotional
acting on Monty Python's Flying Circus
what was really good about it is I was
actually with Cleese who's an impeccable
actor Michael Palin who's a very very
good actor Chapman is an real natural
actor and Terry Jones who was a very
good comic actor so when you're in a
group you saw copying or you you're
lifted up by their performances and that
encourages you to go a bit further and
be more confident in doing what you're
doing and this was one of the first
things I actually auditioned for the
Pythons Reid audition on sketches it was
sort of based on two things there was
vivian stanshall from the Bonzo Dog
doo-dah band would always do a bit of
that and also there was a character in
my pub her time called Monty was why we
named the show Monty actually his little
bowtie and he's very jolly whose life
and soul of the party it's a very
popular character it was played on
American television when we recorded it
in 1973 on The Midnight Special
and Elvis called everybody's Squire
because of that [ __ ] sketch which is
amazing to me I just nearly died when I
found that out I was just love that now
I mean sky
hey so an Elvis used to do [ __ ]
Python sketch is in bed with his
girlfriend Linda Thompson at night
including the Pepper Potts idea
oh if only there was footage
the richest sketch I wrote with John
Cleese and wrong the rare things I wrote
with John it occurred to me a lot of
Australians were called Bruce because I
have a lot of Australian friends unless
the idea at everybody's call Bruce it's
kind of fun when everybody talks the
same when everybody's call the same I
think the best thing that it turned into
a song the Philosopher's song which I
really liked I think I think I had the
most fun at the Hollywood Bowl when I
played that character because we I could
ad-lib in that character you know Bruce
and I said you know look at this -
Hollywood Bowl it's a typical Hollywood
crowd all the kids are on drugs and all
the adults are on rollerskates was true
of that time that's a sketch written by
John and Graham I wrote the second half
of it and it gets into a long rant which
I really love the rats it goat I used to
I had to learn it so it was page after
page either he won't stop talking
I'm Michael Palin Spencer all the
interviews trying to stop him talking
shut up go away I like smoke too much it
was very good I could do that up to
about the age of 65 or 62 then he's just
just like oh I can't do this monologue
any longer is about 10 minute monologue
I think Python pretty largely was about
television it was on television and it
was about television it was reflected
all the sort of shows that were on
television and the money program was a
real program and it said the money
program money talking about money
Deutsche Mark and and he just then gets
up and goes into this beautiful song and
dance and all these singers come on
dressed as Welsh ladies for reasons and
I don't think there are any reasons and
I write I think almost the first song I
did on Python I kind of enjoyed doing
that song I like that song the ruffles
which was called all you need is cash
the world's first mockumentary by the
way I had done a clip of the Rutles for
the song Neil Innes roads and they
played it on Saturday Night Live when I
first did it in about 76 maybe and it's
a bit I'd written it's about that means
if you're talking very sincerely to
camera and he's talking and the camera
starts to move away any moves towards it
as they do and you keep walking walking
and then the camera would go faster and
faster for us and ended up running down
the street and then Lorne Michaels said
to me what are you doing this I said
well I think that might make a whole
documentary I'm doing on BBC two and he
said no make it for NBC with me and
you'll get a much bigger budget it was
fun I got Neil Innes to write 12 new
Beatles songs I didn't have a lead I
didn't have a Paul and so I sort of
backed into playing that role as well so
I didn't really want to but when I did
it was interesting to study Paul I think
his wife and liked it the most
Lynda loved that performance because
he's look he's playing with his eyes of
his to shoot me down in flames if I
could tell them that so it's really a
parody of documentary style talking
people talk variously to camera and they
emphasize words that wouldn't normally
be emphasized they talk like that why I
don't know and it was later used by
stolen by The Simpsons which I didn't
exactly say manner
he's supposed to making documentaries
talking to camera about the Simpsons
well if you want I can cut you out of
the film No
it was fun playing the Beatles I mean it
was really fun getting dressing up in
the streets and running around and I
liked that it was the most probably on
the most fun times to have a hand
filming the Holy Grail was the most
miserable time I mean it was [ __ ]
awful we're up in Scotland the day
before we went filming the Scottish
National Commission of something decided
we were not allowed to use their castles
any of them so we were stuck with one
castle called dune castle which we shot
from every single bloody act which was
in private hand and now it's a tourist
trap you can go there and go into every
scene from the Holy Grail they've got it
all set up which I'm very happy for I
think it's funny because it was
unpleasant and I think uncomfortable is
very good for comedy and not enough
money is excellent for comedy I think
that was just a cadence I heard bring it
you're dead you know bring bring it you
did the dead collector so you haven't
even have a name she a lot of our
characters are man number three person
in queue man with hair on fire
please had the funniest because he's
bringing out this man on his shoulder so
it's kind of against or two people
Hagley impress somebody else did they
want to throw on the cards and I think
the only good thing about the dead
collectors I actually have one of the
very few genuine ad-libs in Python
somebody said who's that then I said
he's a king I said why is that [ __ ] oh I
remember and that was a genuine ad-lib
because we were writers we didn't run a
live on our [ __ ] film scene there
might you write that do the script
we each got to play a knight and mine
was Sir Robin and he's just basically a
coward it's kind of fun to play a coward
you know I think it's quite nice because
I wrote that song bravely bolster Robin
Ponca I'm a lot from this day enjoying
this and he was not at all afraid to
have his legs legs capped off and his
bottom burned out he's like one of those
things you're gonna just reveal growing
unhappiness with the song so Robin had a
thing I wrote which is not very good
it's like a three-headed night but
they're bickering all the time it didn't
make the musical oh yes this is my
favorite and that scene is all one take
that's why it's funny
please says always the funniest thing is
stupidity the mic is saying right Scott
stay here and I'll come back in a minute
and mine just is very stupid not to
leave the room until you or anybody had
not anybody else so he's trying to
understand his north country he's from
the Yorkshire but he can't really
understand the instructions just to stay
here just just playing stupid this is
all it is and it's delicious fun to play
and Graham all he's doing it's big this
is just as Hicks but he times them so
perfectly
it never treads on a laugh it never
turns on a line and it's how not to
upstage people it's a perfect lesson in
that
nearly departed which was very quickly
departed
well I remember very little this it was
a sitcom they came to me so would you
play a ghost who haunts this place we
did it for a bit and it wasn't very
funny and I said to them look the only
way this would be funny is if this was a
black family and their haunted by this
[ __ ] awful English professor white
guy hanging around I'll be funny
then I said well we can't do that no we
can't do that it's America I think that
was what was wrong with her the script
there wasn't enough conflict there has
to be real conflict to be funny I think
it only lasted about six and I think the
only broadcast about three I'm not going
to sit calm I hate it I'm no good at it
I've done it twice and both times it was
disastrous so don't ask me okay
I won't do it the life of Brian came out
of an ad-lib I made when a journalist
asked me what our next movie was going
to be I said Jesus Christ lust for glory
John Cleese said I think that's very
interesting nobody's ever been funny
about religion who read the Dead Sea
Scrolls we studied texts we studied
terrible Hollywood movies you know
surely this man is the son of God and so
our movies a kind of parody of a
Hollywood biblical epic and we realized
we couldn't really write about JC
because there's nothing you can complain
about it man saying you know blessed are
the poor feed and help people there was
something more interesting about
exploring what followers of a religion
do both to the religion and to the
people they follow and how unhealthy
that becomes
well mr. cheeky is based on our sparks
the electric lighting guys there's some
people you want in the trenches nothing
would get them down so we wrote this
sort of character mr. cheat he's got
based on that you know they said
crucifixion he says now now they said I
could go free and live on an island
somewhere
now I'm Andy pulling your leg it's a
crucifixion really we've ended the film
with a song which I'd written and I done
the demo and it wasn't very good it was
like some things in life are better and
they can really was sung very straight
and rather boringly and I realized that
the song should be sung by the character
I was playing because he's been
crucified now some things you know if I
Bank I can really monument is much
funnier because it's giving an ironic
background to the song wise look on the
bright side
[Music]
I think this is amazing how prescient
Stan
aka Loretta is because he's a
transgender person appearing suddenly in
the life of Brian I realized that I
would have to play it very sincerely and
that he'd have to mean that I want to be
a woman I want to have a baby it has to
be believable he has to want to have a
baby I said well where you're gonna keep
the fetus you're gonna keep it in a box
where is it going to gestate don't you
oppress me I'm not pressing you stand it
deals with I think from 1978
it's very germane at the particular at
this moment in time
John Dupree and I after Spamalot we
adapted the life of Brian as an oratorio
and so we wrote a song called I want to
be a girl for Stan which is very sweet
and very tender I want to be a girl Mike
Nichols who was a very severe about this
would always say to the actors you must
believe in what you're doing because if
you don't believe in it why would you
expect the audience to and I said Mike
you're talking about the Knights who say
me who nevertheless they must believe
how the Knights Hussaini The Adventures
of Baron Munchausen six months of Hell
under Gilliam you know there's a
disaster we drove down from France and
they said oh we've delayed the shooting
two weeks you know well couldn't you've
told us we're here now and it was one of
those films where everything went wrong
just absolutely everything he didn't
have enough money it was made in three
languages and Italian English and
Spanish
you know I say in my book I would rather
go back to boarding school than back in
to Munchausen and they shaved my head
every day this is great Gilliam lights
and if I shave my head he'd shave his
lire I show man he said good that's fine
uh there were three ages and sometimes
you'd be made up for three hours first
thing in the morning and you turn at me
oh no no no you're supposed to be young
today he likes to create chaos because
he's an animator and he's only happy
when there's chaos and he's solving it
but for the rest of us who are the chaos
it was not so much fun I don't remember
very much about that character except
when I tried on the costume they had
these huge thighs I said the Wardrobe
lady it looks like he's got no dick get
me an artificial dick and she knitted
one and stuck it in there so I thought
that was the motivation with this
character your big thighs and a huge
dick I kept the dick by the way I have
that dick still being Italian they'd
also knitted the ball so it's really
nice the cat saw destiny CATSA which i
think means [ __ ] and it's our him
[Music]
Kaspar I think Spielberg produced it and
they asked me if I'd be in this movie
it's a special-effects film so there's
hours of waiting around which you
remember more than the actual acting
bits because it's much longer and I
don't remember much about dibs I don't
think I've seen it for a while you were
playing the boyfriend they want a
wannabe boyfriend of Kathy Moriarty I
think and this is dibs but I don't
remember very much about the movie at
all actually
except you know there were some nice
people around Alan Smithee is the name
that the guild put on a film when the
directors taken his name off it and so I
was playing Alan Smithee the eponymous
director and what he does in the stories
he steals the film he just steals it and
runs away with it and the first cut was
shot quite quite interesting it's
directed by Arthur Hiller who directed
love story and he has Ryan O'Neal in it
with me I was Bruce Willis in it you
know he had real people in it all over
the place and it was some semi
documentary but Arthur Hiller tried to
make it real he tried to put motion in
which I thought was a very right way to
go with it until they fired him so Alice
smithy became the director of the Alan
Smithee film i rather disappointed
because I didn't get a Razzie nomination
and it got five Razzie nominations I
think he won all five as the worst film
worst director worst script but I was
disappointed I didn't even get a
nomination I'll get it one day
honey i shrunk the audience it's a 4d
film which means that it's filmed in 3d
you're wearing glasses but everything
happens in the building special theater
for all these effects about 25 minute
film Rick Moranis was in it we shot it
and it was kind of interesting as you
had to do it with long takes like a play
because they were adding in all the
special effects then I got to write one
which was the Pirates in 4d with Leslie
Nielsen and I wrote some jokes you know
what the pigeons go overhead and they
they drop water on people's heads and
they think they're going poop on the
heads yeah we shot that one in Puerto
Rico it was really great fun I'm not a
pirate ship because Leslie insisted I
was in the movie or he wouldn't do it
and so he had a lot of fun the meaning
of life we had the most trouble with
because we didn't know what it was about
I always run Python we didn't know what
we were doing we just said well let's
just start writing and see something
emerges and so we start writing bits and
pieces and it became about an expedition
to Afghanistan World War three sponsored
by advertising and you know it has many
good bits and pieces but we couldn't for
the life of us determine what was the
the film is about I said I think what
this could be about is the meaning of
life and they all kind of like that
because that applies to almost
everything it's got some a great parts
which is still very offensive I'm happy
to say vomiting and blood liver donors
there's a couple more scenes missing of
that character because I I remember a
scene just you know doesn't matter the
ER lost a leg quite a fight you good
then yes beauty isn't it he's very
indifferent to pain and then later on I
think there was as Laura seen you all
right yes yes I'm cheating about a lot
he said okay yeah it's just being a bit
horny
he's lost his leg but he's really the
[ __ ] about has made him horny
I don't know well they still have that
some of the things got lost maybe it's
in the app takes I don't know heads at
the tiger michaël of the back end
routines I like that because it's about
lying we were coming down through ages I
just take a lift on the back there's a
pro Czarist a shanty chief know why you
really hit and they won't they never
tell you why they're there dressed as a
tiger so it's a perfect Python thing the
whole thing is talking about why are you
dressed as a tiger and never explaining
it this is all about being funny
avoiding answering the question why
you're dressed as a tiger doesn't matter
why they're dressed as a tiger have they
got my leg
I think Gaston was a gift from Terry
Jones Terry Jones was directing the
whole film this time he gave me two
parts I think one was Gaston and one was
the Protestant wife who we've had sex
twice and we've got two children
very sweet playing little northern lady
because I'm from the north yeah I like
those little voices Gaston was like
French you know French waiter come with
me come with me
there's a big long lead in we take him
all over the bloody place and he starts
to abuse the camera and the audience is
it's it's a gag on the audience so it's
nice [ __ ] off well the man in pink isn't
really a character he sings the galaxy
song which is one of my favorite songs
it's all right with John Duprey and I'd
written all these lyrics about the
universe and the size of it and the
scale of it and well who who was gonna
sing it and then I thought well I'll
wear something extravagant so I got a
pink outfit made and I think we got a
silvery wig and he only talks he just
sings it's not a lot in the character
hurt so much as the the song delivering
the song properly which is kind of sweet
he takes Terry Jones off into the
universe and since although Lady and
brings her back
we're 30,000 light-years from galactic
central point evil right so we said
those aren't the facts and I say they're
not the facts anymore all right the
facking they work in 1982 and they were
the facts then it's science has changed
its mind not me I get a lot of [ __ ] from
Professor Brian Cox he's a particle
physicist and cosmologist and so he's
always giving me [ __ ] saying that's not
the true facts and I did a gag with him
in o2 where I got him run over by
Stephen Hawking which is my favorite
thing ever it's one major physicist
running over another one
it is wheelchair I don't look for
characters I fired my acting agent 20
years ago so I don't want to be in films
I hate it
I'm a writer that's what I like to do I
like to think things up write characters
and get other people to do them and
that's much more fun
[Music]